i am very excited for the conversation
that i'm about to have
um that i'm about to embark on you'll
get the joke in a minute
um this subject is really personal for
me
so i'm really excited because here to
give us some tips on how to keep
our kids safe during the school year and
basically 365 as far as i'm concerned
we have parenting expert and
best-selling author of
parenting in the tech world to tanya
jordan ladies and gentlemen
thank you my gosh
i mean this really is personal for me
and i know it is so personal for you
it really is well we are so excited that
our show
is working with your company bark and i
would love
for you to tell us as parents how does
bark work
barc is an online monitoring solution
for parents
that helps them keep their children
safer online without invading their
privacy
so break down some of the specific
challenges that we
face as a society and parenting with our
kids in tech
i love to use an analogy to really help
it hit home
for everybody watching and listening you
know you don't give your child
a bicycle without making sure they wear
a helmet you don't put them in a car
without a car seat
seat belt etc certainly don't throw them
the keys
to a ferrari and say have fun you know
but that's essentially what we're doing
with these smartphones with these gaming
consoles
with access to social media don't give
your child a device that can access the
entire world
and all of human knowledge without
knowing where they're going
on it what they're doing what they're
experiencing and so
utilize the built-in parental controls
that come
with you know iphones android devices
gaming consoles even netflix
and then on top of that you need to be
monitoring
okay so first of all i'm going to
immediately
uh since your company has been brought
to my attention become a customer
because i've been looking for a solution
like this
because and something you talk about
that i love to anyone who may be
watching
my daughter is a hacker i've put every
preventative measure on there
and she gets rid of all of them um and
it is a personal issue for me because i
want to protect my kids
i have tons of childhood baggage that
like make me even more of a doberman
with my kids you too oh that's a whole
nother episode
plenty plenty of fun stories there um
which i actually will share with my
son because growing up i wasn't told a
lot of things that
could have probably helped me avoid some
of those big boulders in the road
and so on that note i am very open and
honest with him we navigate things
together
and when i did decide to let him have a
smartphone which was
earlier than i wished i had but it's
really hard to dial it back
we talked about the fact that i am not
going to grab your phone
and look through every little thing
because i have bark bark will alert me
when you've encountered
tricky people online predators you know
it gives you insight into your child's
world
but the best part about bark is that it
doesn't just give you the problem here
drew here's the problem good luck we
actually give you best recommended next
steps for how to address
how do you talk to your child in an
age-appropriate way
about the toughest things that you will
ever have to speak about with your child
this just makes me feel so
empowered like i have a chance
at keeping my kids safe yes our goal is
to
empower parents help keep children safer
online and real life and help them
become responsible digital natives
they're growing they grow so fast it's a
whole new world
and we as parents can't really do our
job
now in a tech world without the help of
tech good tech and tech created
by parents for parents and i really want
to stress the fact that it's not a
matter of if but when
at barc just over the course of 2020 we
analyzed over
2.1 billion data points of close to 5.6
million children across the united
states and
and the data's staggering you know close
to
75 percent of children experienced cyber
bullying
either as a bully uh or or witness or
victim
the inappropriate content stats will
shake you to your core
so because it's not a matter of if but
when go ahead and get that bike helmet
get that insurance put the batteries in
your fire and carbon monoxide detector
and when your children access tech make
sure you're using barc
how does it help parents yes and so i'm
so glad you asked thank you
to everybody who's listening and
watching right now let's break it down
what you do is you go to bark.us either
on a computer on your smartphone
whatever go to our website bark.us
and you sign up for a free trial and you
connect your children's devices and
accounts
over 30 social media platforms text
messages
email i mean you might not realize but
your kids are encountering these sort of
things even in like
google docs at school it's a thing and
so bark will connect to your children's
devices and accounts
we'll help walk you through the setup
process and then
you'll get alerts when your children
have encountered issues we'll send you
an alert via text message
via email and we'll not only tell you
what happened
and where it happened but thankfully
bark will give you best recommended next
steps for how
to address what do you do from a legal
standpoint how do you talk to your child
how do you and your child navigate this
new tech world together
as someone who would have
probably craved some boundaries and some
protection when i was younger
thank you for what you are helping our
generation
deal with with our own kids thank you
thank you so much
you